je vous donnais une petite pochette pour
le transport merci d'accord vous ne
direz pas dé sortir de l'approché comme
chaque année michel houdebine et 84 ans
vient chercher son vaccin contre la
grippe est essentielle parce que quand à
long terme pour la grippe
moi je lui ai eu une fois j'avais
j'étais encore jeune j'étais bien bon
point être jeune en 2010 est de 159
milles yvelinois avait bénéficié d'un
bon de prise en compte plus de 42 %
d'entre eux se sont fait vacciner
nous avons ici la moitié du stock en
réalité parce que nous faisons livré en
deux fois pour des problèmes de places
dont tous les ans le même système et on
s'approvisionne ou plutôt des stops
pensé dès le mois de février
les premiers vaccins sont arrivés à la
fin du mois de septembre
cette pharmacie de saint rémy les
chevreuse a déjà délivré 136 vaccins en
moins d'une semaine on a eu beaucoup de
demandes
même avant le début de la campagne de
vaccination qui a démarré le 5 ou le 6
octobre selon les caisses c'est
important parce que ça protège soi même
et ça protège l'entourage aussi il faut
savoir que des personnes sensibles
peuvent être contaminés par des
personnes non vaccinées
je parle des petits enfants et des
personnes âgées
cette année encore dans les yvelines
c'est le médecin ou l'infirmier qui fait
l'injection mais les pharmaciens
pourraient bientôt vacciner eux-mêmes
une expérimentation est en cours dans
quatre autres départements français